Gang Gang what's up man this is dusty
from Leesburg Georgia
what's up dusty over here in Leesburg
huh and Leesburg Georgia and that is um
man I sound like a small place that's
not my kind of place where everybody
kind of you know where the water
fountain is you know it sound like you
could definitely go find a wishing well
over there beautiful home we're brother
I just want to call in with install
solar corona virus I love kind of sick
of this half apocalypse everything shut
down half still going work paying my
bills which I am appreciative of because
I understand there's a lot of people out
of there without work and I'm able to
pay the bills but uh I mean yeah I'll
just figure fledgeling in the middle
here we need to choose the side either
everything just needs to go back to how
it was and we figure this [ __ ] out that
way or we go full [ __ ] apocalypse and
we get a couple of dune buggies and a
couple of sets the shoulder pants start
shaving her head to the mohawk speaking
simpler languages you know a man I die
look there's that Ella everybody that's
what I'm saying where everybody's a
lesbian you know I'm saying you fold
your weight your nuts into something and
you next thing you know you got some
four juts down there and everybody's
everybody's a Les Deux Mohawks on
everybody you know what I'm saying
ladies trim your tits down guys sharpen
up your lower ribs and expose Umbra and
let's [ __ ] go toe to toe I'm look
there's something to be said there's a
there's the I think that seed is like
that that seed lives in a lot of us
somewhere that element of anarchy you
know what I'm saying we got that [ __ ]
violent onion smelling up our insides
you know that thing is in there and not
there's a lot of people who are who are
who are kind of like a society Sh'ma sia
tea they don't feel that the you know
the Rhonda John or the you know the this
this human gumbo that we have going on
is the best
is the best for it's not that it's not
the it doesn't really fulfill their
appetite but I feel it is this
middle-ground thing like okay like okay
like I don't have my windows tinted on
my on my truck right so I'm at that
point where I'm like okay do I need it
can I go get them tinted or can I break
them all out and hire a couple of
straight-up beautiful ass [ __ ] lean
lean with it rock with it vietze to hang
out the back and shoot with slingshots
as I as I go as I Drive like that's
where I'm at like what things do I need
to do and what things can I not like
like where am I at like okay can I still
go to the grocery or is it okay to just
turn my living room into a damn garden
okay cuz I got enough room for three
rows of sweet patate right in front of
the damn ottoman and right before you
get to that um dual deck CD a ten disc
er you know I there's it's it's just
kind of everything's in the middle like
what do I got two sides in my sink in my
kitchen like do I still need to just do
the dishes at night or I do I need to
plug both of those [ __ ] up and start
raising farm fresh salmon and one half
of it and shrimp and the other you feel
me you know I was gonna have some shrimp
so there's that middle ground there it's
like okay or you know am I still married
to my wife like how weird does [ __ ] have
to get before I'm just like how long
does the courthouse have to be closed
down before I can this kind of walk on
off you know but before the marriage
certificate there's nowhere to even go
cash that thing in it it's interesting
it's interesting because society is just
like kind of a stack of things that
happen you know man gets a little
property he gets a why
and then they have a family and then you
know enough families needed we're
teaching their kids and say well okay
let's you know we got too many kids
let's hire does one person to teach them
all and so then then one person was the
best part the best teacher in the
neighborhood became the teacher and the
kids all went to her and that's how a
school started then you got a school and
he said this man over here okay I'm good
at making uh boots I'll make all the
boots
all right cool Donnie you do the boots
now bucko
you to boot man Donnie and everybody
gets their thing and it builds but then
man it's definitely there's a little bit
of jiangha in the air it's like oK we've
been there's a lot been this thing's
been this thing's starting to sway in
the wind a little you know these step
kids are a how you know they're not even
really mine at this point shit's hitting
the fan they're not doing [ __ ] they in
there they own the tablets all day they
every time I orange comes off our orange
tree they get out there and sneak it I'm
saying daddy you don't have any vitamin
C my spines getting all [ __ ] bent out
because I don't have the proper vets in
me what's going on you know it's do I
still have to be a stepparent like that
you know things it's gonna get
interesting man but I feel you I wish
they would just shut the news down and
say hey look it's every man for himself
but then also that's just a little part
of me that wants that the other part of
me is like a man let's get shipped back
organized because uh you know because
people have things that they need it you
know people are missing regular things
people are missing their birthdays
they're missing this and I was thinking
what imagine some kids miss promised
year imagine that imagine you're in
senior year of high school and they
don't have it that would not a soft my
senior year
this was it man this was you were gonna
get off and everything was gonna happen
he was gonna maybe get a little teddy or
something from your girl Veronica or
whatever whatever you Nova Ranch Allah
whatever your girl's name was Kisha
whoever whoever copy you know whoever's
letting loose that evening tit that
little baby milk jug that was gonna let
you touch you know on the same people
had plans okay I'm gonna get it you know
I'm gonna I'm gonna do well on
basketball I'm gonna get my scholarship
people had plans what about prom you
think of all the high school seniors are
not getting to go to prom this year nope
dude prom was it prom women prom man now
you can't how you gonna do what are you
gonna do you're gonna order a prom you
can do Amazon prom you're gonna get
you're gonna do an Amazon prominent
gonna bring you a little it's just a
little box and they gotta you know they
got a bunch of liquor in there and you
and you have to drink it real early and
then listen to some music that you don't
remember and then they just they also in
there there's a picture of you two and
it's this you got to vomit in your
buddy's car and then they already put
the picture a picture together if you
just passed out and your girlfriend's
driving you home cuz you passed out in
the back because your boy Lance gave you
a couple hits a bad acid bra a couple
bootleg shitty with his cousin made man
that little [ __ ] paper mache you know
kaleidoscope starter it's just I don't
know just a mad but yeah it's like you
think about all the things you were that
could be affected and that are being
affected there's a you know there's just
it's it's so interesting I mean all the
different down to the minutiae of things
the little things
somebody had a trip planned to uh engage
themselves to get engaged to someone
asking to marry
to do family start family you know and
now that's been postponed okay our trip
I don't know do I still and now we're
fighting and now with the and now we
might not even be together what the hell
what the hell Sharlee SHhhh we were
supposed to if this was gonna be
something we was going to barb at us you
know we had two first-class tickets to
Barbados and we was gonna be lovers you
know and now we [ __ ] fightin so it's
just it's interesting man it's
interesting and also it's interesting
how many things we expect you know how
much I expected I expected things to be
the same oh I didn't realize I was
living in and this system of like of
needs and once I was you know this human
created cosmo of society and now it's
mother nature plate you ever played uno
and mother nature just plays that uh
what does it call skip-bo yeah I think I
let me see what it's called skip-bo yeah
remember that skip-bo i think it was
like uno or something and but then
somebody play skip-bo and a whole [ __ ]
changed whatever plans you had I'm gonna
do three of a kind seven of a kind I'm
gonna touch somebody's ass when the
power goes out and then steal a couple
cards and cheat people had plans but
mints and then somebody played skip-bo
or it was in the deck now what now what
and you find out somebody's been
touching yo ass now what and that's what
we're doing mother nature said hey you
didn't see I got this card you didn't
see that I that there's you living out
here on my titty on my belly y'all been
out here doing this and doing NASCAR and
doing our you know hedge funds and
[ __ ]
threesomes and all of that y'all doing
that on my ass on my backside on my
front side on my side side and suddenly
man there's some realism hmm okay
there's somebody else playing ball here
there's something else at work
that's nature man it's fascinating
really but the levels the levels of
people that people are dealing with this
at and the different things and and how
people are handle in it it's all pretty
fascinating I think it's really
fascinating honestly I think it's very
fascinating good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one
watches one